oui
[Musique]
il
bonjour bienvenue dans la grande
interview aujourd'hui nous avons le
plaisir de recevoir frédéric pierre
ruetschi ancien cadre dirigeant d'alstom
aujourd'hui directeur du cabinet de
conseil icariens bonjour frédéric pierre
ruetschi merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation
deux ans ont passé depuis la publication
de votre livre le piège américain dans
lequel vous décrivez les dessous de la
vente d' alstom general electric votre
calvaire dans une prison américaine
en tant que taj afin d'obliger alstom à
payer une amende de 12 milliards d'euros
vous avez des treilles par vos avocats
vous avez passé 14 mois dans la prison
de très haute sécurité
qu'est ce qui vous a aidé à tenir durant
cette épreuve merci déjà de votre
invitation donc effectivement c'était
une épreuve très compliqué pour ma
famille surtout et moi ce qui m'a aidé à
tenir ça a été surtout de relativiser ce
qui m'arrivait dans ces prisons
américaines il faut tuer le temps donc
je me suis occupé en fait tu fais comme
si je travaille je travaille et de 8
heures du matin à huit heures du soir
j'ai étudié la jurisprudence sur sur
cette loi ce qui m'a permis de voile à
2,2 de m'appliquer de réfléchir et de
vraiment tuer le temps ce qui m'a permis
aussi de relativiser les choses c'est de
de comparer - situation à la situation
d'autres personnes très proches ils sont
dans des situations bien pires que les
miennes par exemple voilà j'ai réfléchi
un petit peu mon père qui avait fait la
guerre d'algérie mon grand père qui
avait fait deuxième guerre mondiale -
enfers qu'a fait la première guerre
mondiale je me suis dit bon c'est vrai
si terrible que ça ce qui t'arrive par
rapport à des gens très très proches
quand les gens des choses beaucoup plus
compliqué que ce que tu vis
des actions en deux et six américains
contre vous maintenant non le cas le cas
est finie c'est moi qui une action en
justice contre mon ancienne entreprise
parce qu'elle m'a licencié et donc je
suis aux prud'hommes contre contre
alstom fin qui maintenant a été racheté
par des vérins électriques et comment ça
se passe cette action de justice
ça traîne depuis 2000 14 ans nous sommes
aux prud'hommes et on est quasiment 2022
ya tueur pas de décision de première
instance et vous vous avez une
explication enfin
je pense que c'est un sujet que beaucoup
de gens ne veulent pas voir remettre sur
la table
mais pour l'instant donc les podiums bas
même beaucoup beaucoup de temps mais là
c'est vrai que dans ce cas précis c'est
vraiment extrêmement long et comment
votre livre a été
perçue aux états unis
alors été publié en langue anglaise
au début du coc vide donc ça a été la
meilleure période pour une sortie de
livres comme les livrets à étaient été
fermé mais il ya quand même eu eux
plusieurs dizaines de milliers
d'exemplaires qui ont été vendus j'ai eu
surtout beaucoup de réactions de
l'université américaine qui m'ont
contacté pour pour faire des débats là
bas parce que c'est quand même c'est pas
un pays modèle bloque les états unis et
beaucoup de gens qui s'insurge contre
les dérives du droit et notamment de la
justice négocier et de du super pouvoir
des procureurs actuellement du
department of justice donc j'ai eu pas
mal de d'avocats aussi qui m'ont
contacté en me disant je vais raison
d'écrire ce livre
parce qu'ils ne seront ne connaissent
plus dans dans leur métier d'avocat ils
sont allés à l'école pour défendre des
entreprises défendre des individus et
dans leur demande de négocier en fait
avec des supers procureur même chose
pour les beaucoup de juges ne se
retrouvent plus dans un ampli en cette
justice parce qu'ils sont venus ce qu'on
appelle des juges tampon qui simplement
mettre un tampon sur des accords prêt
négocié entre des entreprises
d'individus et enée super procureur donc
si vous bien comprendre c'est que les
peines de prison et un vestaire
extrêmement longue
et
étant dans un système de justice
négocier 90% des personnes qui sont
inculpés plaident coupable ne pourrait
éviter des peines de prison extrêmement
longue et pour travailler maintenant il
est connu aux états unis
elle est connue au moins dans dans le
cercle académique et dans le cercle des
spécialistes du droit ça c'est sûr
maintenant jeunes auprès du grand public
je n'en suis beaucoup moins sûr mais en
tous les cas ce je sais que ça fait ça
fait débat quelles répercussions de la
publication de votre livre sur votre vie
actuelle
en fait moi j'ai je vais deux choses
lorsque je suis sorti de prison j'ai
d'abord fait beaucoup de l'activité de
lobbying avec avec l'ancien bâtonnier de
paris pour convaincre l'état français de
changer la loi anticorruption française
afin de protéger les entreprises
françaises donc nous avions organisé
notamment à l'assemblée nationale un
débat qui s'appelait après elle se
maquille tour pour sensibiliser les
députés insistent et de changer la loi
française pour les propos protéger les
entreprises
donc en 2016 il ya une nouvelle loi
anticorruption française qui est qui
était promulguée beaucoup d'autres l'ont
fait ont
emboîté le pas et ont aussi poussé pour
que cette loi sorte même les entreprises
pensent a donc voulu que cette loi sorte
et puis à dire une chose si les faits
j'ai créé ma société de conseil pour
sensibiliser les cadres les
les commerces des grandes entreprises
sur ces sujets de déstabilisation
potentielle de leur entreprise c'est à
cause d'eux pour un de corruption donc
en fait on assiste les entreprises à
mettre en place des programmes
anti-corruption solide donc quelque
chose a changé dans les esprits des
dirigeants français peut-être je pense
que beaucoup de choses ont changé si
vous voulez avant l'affairé alsthom il y
avait déjà eu plusieurs entreprises
françaises qui avaient payé des amendes
extrêmement importante au trésor
américain donc il y avait eu au total
technip alcatel en tout sur les dix
dernières années les entreprises
françaises ont fait plus de 14 milliards
de dollars d'amendé au trésor américain
pour enfreinte à différentes lois
extraterritoriales américaine que ce
soit sur la corruption sur le contrôle
des exportations sur le respect des
embargos des sanctions américaines donc
c'est beaucoup beaucoup d'argent est en
fait l'affairé alsthom a été le déclic
qui a fait je pense comprendre les
risques de cet extra territorialité
américaine et maintenant il n'y a pas
une semaine en france sans qu'il n'y ait
une conférence où un débat sur ce jeu
sur ce sujet là parce qu'en fait depuis
les etats unis ont fourbi leur arsenal
de lois extraterritoriales peu près tous
les ans ou tous les deux ans une
nouvelle loi qui sort
donc notamment récemment sur les données
stratégie de captation de données qui
permettent à lille voilà de capter
énormément de données dans des
entreprises étrangères comment
voyez-vous votre ouvrage maintenant
après avoir pris une certaine distance
après lecture peut-être auriez-vous
écrit quelque chose différemment
aujourd'hui
en fait j'avais deux choix en écrivant
déjà j'ai écrit ce livre en prison que
j'ai écrit plus de 2000 pages des
analyses à la fin il a fallu faire un
choix entre soit écrire un livre qui
était en treillis mais grand public pour
sensibiliser un peu le maximum de
personnes sur ce sujet là soin d'écrire
en gros une thèse sur
la loi américaine d'efforts nicholas
krafft
donc j'ai choisi effectivement d écrire
un livre grand public parce que je pense
que c'était important de passer ce
message pour sensibiliser le maximum de
personnes notamment les cadres des
entreprises donc je pense que j'ai fait
le bon choix simon pêche peur
actuellement de réfléchir à écrire
quelque chose de beaucoup plus technique
pour bat pour peut-être un public moins
large aujourd'hui et le piège américain
sort en russe à pourquoi peut-être avoir
choisi la russie peut-être vous êtes
vous croyez qu'il ya un public est
particulièrement sensible à votre
calvaire si
c'est vrai c'est que c'est que en fait
cet extrait américaine s'applique à
toutes les entreprises donc c'est vrai
que les états unis ont d'abord commencé
par cibler des entreprises
de l'europe de l'ouest et du japon parce
que dans les années 2000 2010 c'était le
prince étaient les principaux
concurrents des entreprises américaines
mais depuis quelques années en fait
toutes les entreprises un peu de tous
les pays sont ciblés dont des
entreprises russes ont trouvé chinoise
aux prises brésilienne et c'est donc en
fait le livre a été traduit très
rapidement dans une dizaine de langues
donc en japonais en coréen
en bien évidemment en anglais
en arabe
donc c'était assez logique à un moment
il soit traduit aussi en russe le pense
il ya encore deux trois traductions qui
sont en cours dans d'autres langues il
est même sorti en bande dessinée donc
d'accord et nous avons vu un aussi après
l'introduction des sanctions en 2014
notamment qui touche également le
secteur financier que les entreprises
françaises basées en russie je cite un
cadre français avait du mal fois se
faire financer de peur de répéter
justement le destin de bnp paribas par
exemple à châtel moyens de lutter contre
ces principes américains
d'extraterritorialité il ya plusieurs
moyens en fait il ya déjà eu il ya
plusieurs lois donc allé voir sur l'anti
corruption elle voit sur les sanctions
les embargos
ce que nous avons fait en france au
moins sur la partie sur la partie
anticorruption si nous avons fait notre
propre loi qui impose une entreprise
française de mettre un certain nombre de
programmes de procédures en place à
l'intérieur de l'entreprise pour élever
le niveau des entreprises françaises au
niveau du standard international en
termes de lutte contre la corruption et
je pense que ça sera chose qui serait
intéressante de faire ici si en russie
est le deuxième mécanisme qui avait été
mis en place et est un mécanisme qui
permettait aux entreprises françaises
qui avaient commis des ce genre de
choses dans le passé de faire amende
honorable et d'avouer au parquet
national financiers ce qui s'était passé
à moins et en échange de quoi ils
pouvaient négocier un accord est donc
ceci a permis
d'arrêter cet extra territorialité
notamment sur deux gros cas lequel la
société générale est le cas de deux
airbus ou grâce à cette loi nous avons
pu récupérer plus de 2 milliards
d'amande qui sans cela auraient été
payées aux autorités mais qu'a donc on
commence à faire de
se protéger avec principalement une loi
défensive
est ce qu'il faudrait passer à une loi
offensive c'est à dire à rendre la
monnaie de leur pièce aux états unis en
sanctionnant des entreprises américaines
qui auront enfreint des lois
françaises ou autre peut-être on va voir
je ne sais pas comment ça va évoluer
mais il ya énormément à faire déjà en
remodelant les lois domestiques locales
afin d'être lutter contre cet extra
territorialité justement par rapport à
cette crise de prédation qui pèse
toujours sur les entreprises françaises
la france est elle capable d'y faire d'y
faire face toute seule
alors
c'est très compliqué en tout cas en
l'union européenne d'avoir
un accord à vingt-sept sur ce genre de
sujet
parce que ce qu'on parle du pénal et
chaque état a ses propres lois qui sont
très très différentes par exemple
beaucoup de pays ne criminalise pas
la corruption au niveau des entités
morales à ce que les personnes physiques
qui peuvent être poursuivis pour
corruption qui a déjà pas d'il ya déjà
pas d'harmonisation au niveau national
donc c'est très difficile de faire une
harmonisation au niveau au niveau
européen
donc pour l'instant chaque pays avance à
peu seuls les anglais ont été les
premiers paradoxalement a essayé de
lutter contre un texte c est extra
taille est relatée américaine avec une
première loi en 2010 2011 ensuite les
français les italiens ont aussi remodelé
leur loi les brésiliens vient de le
faire les chinois sont en train de le
faire aussi donc on voit certains pays
qui ont des intérêts convergents
commencé à réagir est ce qu'une
coordination entre ces pays peut-être
pas et c'est là où ce serait intéressant
de de faire cette coordination parce que
pour l'instant à l'intérieur des
vingt-sept d'autres
l'union européenne ne sais pas elle est
très cette corde et sont très très
compliqué mais il faut regarder en
dehors de l'union européenne qu'elle
quelques opérations liées aux prêts y
avoir entre pays qui ont les mêmes
intérêts et capital justement cette
convergence au sein de l'union
européenne peut être et le verra le jour
un jour n'ont peut-être pour l'instant
c'est très compliqué parce que les états
unis aussi
il crée des liens bilatéraux avec un
certain nombre de pays et beaucoup de
pays n'ont rien à gagner à
lutter contre l'extraterritorialité
week-end parce que y'a pas grand chose à
prendre comme d'industrie chez eux si on
prend les pays les plus petits en tous
les cas donc ils n'ont pas trop intérêt
à être trop agressif vis-à-vis des
etats-unis à cause de leurs relations
bilatérales donc c'est plutôt compliqué
quand même de faire ça à 27 donc chacun
pour soi c'est un peu ça un peu ça
[Musique]
vous avez également parlé dans une de
vos interviews que de la politique
industrielle pour préserver les
entreprises françaises en quoi devrait
consister alors ce qu'il faut bien
expliquer d'abord ce sont les
conséquences pour tout le monde de ce
type de prédation
lorsque generic à acheter alstom ils ont
acheté un des joyaux de la couronne du
capitalisme industriel français je vous
rappelle que sous de gaulle il y avait
une grande
promotion de l'indépendance énergétique
française avec un grand programme
nucléaire avec des haies framatome et
alstom est donc en vendant alstom hadj
en afrique nous avons perdu entre nîmes
et le contrôle d'une partie de nos
centrales nucléaires qui la partie des
turbines et donc ce n'est pas rien de
l'avoir perdu ce contrôle là parce que
juste après le rachat tient en afrique a
notamment menacé edf d'arrêter de leur
fournir des pièces de rechange pour nos
centrales nucléaires si s'ils
n'arrivaient pas à renégocier le contrat
commercial donc ça veut dire en gros
mettre le pays dans le noir luc 75 pro
électricité produite par les centrales
nucléaires enfonce donc on parle de
sujets extrêmement grave
donc il ya eu vraiment je pense d'une
certaine prise de conscience
en france sur ce sujet là maintenant
est-ce que nous sommes passés à une
stratégie de reconquête pas vraiment
encore on commence moi même j'avais
préparé un groupement d'investisseurs
pour essayer de racheter ingénieur
électrique cette partie plus stratégique
pour l'instant ça sera peut-être fait
part par edf en tout cas il ya des
discussions en cours
j'espère qu'on va aller au bout de notre
de nos idées et qu'on va effectivement
racheté cette partie là et ça c'est
qu'une petite partie du problème on a
nous avons perdu la pose des câbles
sous-marins la fabrication des câbles
sous marins etc donc nous avons perdu à
tout un tas de pan
je pense que la partie qui
l'événement qui peut faire que les
choses s'accélèrent c'est justement la
période qu'ovide cette période comme il
a démontré la dépendance extrême de
certaines de nos économies à des
économies étrangères
est donc le mot souveraineté
industrielle n'est plus un gros mot en
france c'est ce qui est déjà bien mais
c'est même plus un gros mot sont
maintenant tout le monde en parle tous
les partis politiques en fait on n'a pas
le même programme maintenant c'est à
notre sens de voir ce qui est surtout
crédible pour faire 7 cette souveraineté
industrielle qui est doit se combiner
avec une certaine souveraineté numérique
serait très juridique parce que tout
cela est bien évidemment
un briquet vous avez déjà parlé de de la
pandémie due cori 19 cette pandémie est
là d'une certaine façon
comment at-elle influé sur les tensions
économiques actuelles je pense que
maintenant c'est quelque chose qui est
compris au niveau de chaque français
peut qu'on ne peut plus dépendre sur un
tas de sujets régaliens
de fournisseurs étrangers donc il ya une
nième dans beaucoup de groupes il ya une
réflexion qui est en train d'être fait
pour c'est de rapatrier en france une
partie de la production
donc il ya un vrai sujet de
réinitialisation du pays je le rappelle
que en quinze ans on a perdu quasiment
la moitié de nos emplois industriels en
france
maintenant il va falloir que tout ça
s'accompagne d'une vraie politique pour
faciliter cette année c'est à son
enfance c'est à dire que si on doit
reconstruire des deals usine il faut
qu'on accepte qu'on a une usine qui soit
pas très très loin de là où on habite
c'est donc il ya aussi ce paradoxe aussi
donc on veut réaliser mais on n'est pas
prêts à avoir des usines à côté de chez
nous donc ça il va falloir un
accompagnement j'espère que ce sera fait
dans le monde dans les prochaines années
parce que
il ya tout à y gagner en termes de
balance du commerce extérieur
d'emploi et en termes de
d'indépendance sur internet de sujets
régaliens pensez vous que ça puisse être
un sujet un enjeu de la présidentielle
qui s'approche en france ça va être un
des grands enjeux je pense que là tout
le monde a à peu près un programme où on
reparle de de réindustrialisation de de
souveraineté numérique de soi une telle
juridiction internet réel etc donc je le
pense avoir eu tous les partis utilise
ce mot maintenant alors que encore une
fois c'est un gros mot ya quasiment un
an
donc après on va voir qui est crédible a
en fait pour vraiment mettre en place ce
genre
de programme en est ce qu'il est
possible de faire un pronostic
concernant cette guerre économique qui
est en cours et il assuré que les états
unis seront gagnants en fin de compte à
ma pour l'instant sans réaction ils sont
plus que les 100 plus que gagnant
alors les pays qui ont le plus réagi à
cet extra territorialité sont pour
l'instant
comme je vous l'aï dit les anglais les
chinois ont été ciblés beaucoup plus
tard que les pays on va dire de l'europe
de l'ouest mais réagissent très
rapidement par exemple ils ont
promulgué en 2020 et 2021 3 loi de
sanctions contre sanctions
en chine ce qui va mettre tout le monde
dans des situations de conflit de lois
c'est à dire que tout le monde va dire
ce que vous allez signer des contrats
commerciaux vous allez avoir quatre ou
cinq lois qui vont s'appliquer à ces
contrats commerciaux et ces lois vont
être général contradictoires ça va être
compliqué de ne pas enfreindre une loi
parce que bien évidemment chacun va voir
midi à sa porte ça serait très compliqué
de chéri ça le problème c'est qu'il ya
personne ne fait la loi en outre il met
au dessus l'om c'est en
quasi-faillite en morale en tous les cas
le cd
les règles ne sont pas claires et
d'ailleurs tout le monde et pas ne fait
pas partie de l'eau c'est donc pour
l'instant le commerce mondial c'est très
compliqué personne ne fait ne fait le
gendarme en
est cette guerre se fait de plus en plus
via le droit
qui est grave une arme suprême parce que
là vous arrivez à déstabiliser
d'entreprise à la roche allait racheter
sans
s'en faire de deux coups très très
médiatique et donc
il n'ya pas de danse trans
supranationale qui régule le droit même
en europe c'est compliqué et entre
l'europe les états unis et la chine et
la russie etc c'est compliqué d'avoir
une harmonisation de tout ça donc
effectivement
pour les entreprises pour les dirigeants
ça va être de plus en plus compliqué
d'accord donc vous êtes plutôt
pessimiste je suis pas pessimiste parce
que
il ya eu si on regarde l'histoire des
états unis avaient attaqué les
entreprises européennes dans les années
80-90 sur les cas sur les poèmes de
cartel de droit la concurrence à
l'époque les européens avaient réagi
avait aussi mis des amendes extrêmement
importante d'entreprises américaines et
maintenant en tout cas sur le droit à la
concurrence chacun absent un châle
dessous de son côté donc à partir du
moment où il ya des réactions il peut y
avoir un équilibre qui se crée entre
tout ce beau monde
pour revenir à ce qui devrait lui être
depuis le début c'est à dire que chacun
s'occupe de ses envies de ses propres
entreprises chacun avant l'achat de chez
lui donc on verra
il faut espérer que ça aille dans cette
direction d'accor merci beaucoup à vous
en prie merci beaucoup
[Musique]